economía en directo América de France 24
Daniel hablando con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela Qué bueno tenerla aquí
vamos a hablar del empleo en América
Latina Danny Cuál es el balance después
de la pandemia de Kobe 19 bueno
Comencemos por el principio Raúl en el
primer semestre de 2020 la peor etapa de
la crisis sanitaria se llegaron a perder
unos 49 millones de empleos en la región
esto según la organización Internacional
del trabajo Los indicadores se han
venido recuperando vamos a verlo en el
gráfico la desocupación incluso bajo al
7,9% desde el 8,7% pre pandémico la
ocupación es de poco más del 57%,
aproximadamente la misma cifra sin
embargo de acuerdo con el más reciente
informe de esta que es la división
laboral de Naciones Unidas es la calidad
de esa recuperación que deja hoy a uno
de cada dos empleados latinoamericanos
en la informalidad conversamos
previamente con Mauricio ella es
economista laboral de la oficina
Regional de América Latina de la oita y
esto nos dijo al respecto
aquí lo que observamos es que la
recuperación desde mediados del año 2020
hasta el primer trimestre de este año
que es donde tenemos información
consistente a nivel regional ha estado
liderado mayormente por puestos de
trabajo informales entre el 50 y 70% 80
en algunos casos de la recuperación
total está explicada por la recuperación
de los puestos de trabajo informales en
un contexto además que cuando uno mide
al primer semestre de este año se
observan en algunos casos ralentización
o incluso caídas en el empleo formal sí
Y esto claramente genera una
preocupación adicional si bien el empleo
formal ya hacia fines del año pasado
había recuperado los países los valores
pre pandemia en este primer semestre
asociado la mayor incertidumbre
y a la ralentización del crecimiento
económico se está observando también
fluctuaciones en ese empleo formal y en
algunos casos disminuciones es decir
Dani que está recuperación laboral se ha
dado a medias claro y es que hay que
tener en cuenta Raúl que América Latina
ya venía con indicadores precarios en
términos de Mercado laboral incluso
desde antes de la pandemia más de la
mitad de sus empleados es informal y en
los últimos 10 años se ha mantenido esa
tendencia ahora que se recuperan también
hay disparidades entre naciones
solamente hay un Común denominador que
es el origen de todos estos problemas la
guerra en Ucrania y sus consecuencias
alzas en la inflación y el bajo
crecimiento para terminar de empeorar
una situación que ya venía mal con la
pandemia en 10 de 14 países con datos la
tasa de desocupación en el primer
trimestre de 2022 todavía no había
recuperado los valores registrados en
igual periodo de 2019
la tasa de ocupación pre pandemia está
Bolivia está Argentina está Brasil con
una tasa muy muy cercana a la que en el
primer trimestre de este año respecto al
primer trimestre del año 2019 y como
países que aún tienen algún camino por
recorrer están en Chile está en Costa
Rica como como ejemplo de estos países
que todavía tienen que dar un paso más
para para llegar a los valores
pre pandemia que a nivel regional ya
evidenciaban en el 2019
déficit importantes en materia laboral
no no solo en términos del volumen de
ocupación en el 2019 la tasa de
desocupación promedio de la región era
8%, y además se sumaba esto que
mencionaba previamente el 50% de
informalidad laboral con lo cual Volver
al 2019 no significa volver a una
situación exenta de déficit laborales
claro y por supuesto Dani entre estas
principales preocupaciones tras
pandemias está la pérdida del poder
adquisitivo tan importante que es lo que
finalmente mueve la economía a todos
Raúl porque la hoy te cita a económica
para América Latina y el Caribe la cepal
para señalar que en 2021 los salarios
reales promedio de 12 países analizados
en la región habían perdido un 6,8% del
valor que tenían en 2019 además entre el
50 y el 80% de las ocupaciones generadas
en el proceso de recuperación del que
estamos hablando han sido en condiciones
de informalidad la hoyt también analiza
algo Raúl que se conoce como salario
mínimo real Entonces esto refleja el
verdadero poder adquisitivo de las
personas porque se calcula con base en
el ingreso que sí ha venido subiendo
pero también la inflación que
contrarresta esa subida es decir puede
que el salario haya aumentado en este
tiempo pero si también lo hizo la
inflación el trabajador termina
perdiendo poder adquisitivo en este caso
el país es como México que en 2022 tenía
un salario mínimo real 45 veces o 45%
más alto que en 2019 y otros como
Argentina en donde ese mínimo real ha
caído 10 justamente por la inflación
porque el salario ha subido más del 60%
en este periodo pero la inflación
también ha hecho lo propio
lo que empieza a ser particularmente
preocupante es la caída que vienen
observando los salarios reales de la
mano o consecuencias o asociados al
proceso aceleración inflacionaria
entonces de hecho por ejemplo hay un
dato particular en el informe que tiene
que ver con mirar qué está pasando o
dónde se ubican los salarios mínimos
reales el poder adquisitivo de los
salarios mínimos en el primer trimestre
de este año y sabéis el primer trimestre
del año 2019 y observamos en que el 9 de
los 17 países para los cuales Contamos
con la información el salario mínimo es
más bajo que en aquel momento no ir a y
para finalizar Danny está este bloque
económico cifra del día bueno nos vamos
a poner un poquito optimistas pero para
eso lastimosamente toca salir de América
Latina porque Mire le tengo cifras 38
países que conforman la organización
para la cooperación el desarrollo
económicos También conocido como el club
de países ricos o la ocde Pues los que
mejor pagan el salario mínimo en estos
38 países son Luxemburgo con casi 16
dólares la hora seguido de Australia
Nueva Zelanda Reino Unido Francia y
Alemania este último con 10,59 dólares
la hora ningún latinoamericano en ese
ranking a pesar de que tenemos cuatro
allá en esa ocd bueno Gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica ni como siempre Un gusto nos
vemos más adelante más adelante nos
vemos Claro que sí